a royal watcher in London is recovering
from serious injuries after she was
struck by prince william and kate's
motorcade this was the scene after a
royal police motorcycle escort collided
with an elderly woman on Monday while
William and Kate were on their way to
Windsor for the Royal Garter ceremony 83
year old IRA Mayer was struck and
reportedly suffered a broken pelvis and
other injuries Kensington Palace tells
ET that Kate and William were deeply
saddened by the accident and released
this statement quote their Royal
Highnesses have sent their very best
wishes to Irene and her family and will
stay in touch throughout every stage of
her recovery William and Kate have
reportedly sent flowers and have asked
to visit Irene when she is up to it
meanwhile it looks as if the Fab Four
are splitting up at least when it comes
to their charity the royal foundation a
royal source says that the foundation
will be divided between the Cambridge's
and the sus exes as William and Kate
began to prep for when they become king
and queen the couples are on better
footing than they have been in the past
according to our source just last year
when the four appeared at a foundation
event they confirmed that they sometimes
clashed working as family challenges of
course as everybody here thought I was
laughing and our source also reports
Megan will be guest editing the
September issue of British Vogue and
focus on women's humanitarian issues the
palace says you have to confirm the move
and it is not yet known if Megan will do
a cover shoot like he did in 2016 to
celebrate the magazine's 100th
anniversary
you
[Applause]
[Music]